[Music]
i wanted i was thinking
about the uh communication problem
uh the so-called communicating with
extraterrestrial intelligence
and i wanna uh understand if you have a
perspective on this because
as you make the case so often a lot of
language is as you're saying is
is not even the verbal or structural or
even the the
linear processes by which language can
be acquired
uh by human beings and uh and yet if you
imagine the problem
of communicating with an
extraterrestrial civilization using
purely using a printer or using binary
code or some such uh
form of flashing uh lights converted
into
into uh morse code perhaps is it
and assuming the intelligence could
decipher such a thing first of all
assuming they exist by the way do you
believe that there are extraterrestrial
civilizations
i promise this won't be a long uh what's
that
fear me paradox yes do you believe that
they exist or do you have a
reason to suspect that they might not
intelligent communicating technological
intelligence
they may in fact they may be all up
there
if they have any intelligence and they
pay any attention to what's going on on
earth
they'll get far away
as creatures like us that's right that's
probably the answer to the family
paradox
but there may be extra special
inheritance maybe not
and then assuming that notice
intelligence is a
very rare property uh
you may have seen ernst meyer's article
and it's responding to
uh carl sagan you've seen that
discussion interesting discussion so
carl sagan's from the point of view of
an astrophysicist
is it's got to be all these planets out
there very much like ours so
it's got to be like this now meyer from
the point of view of biologists he was
the grand old man of american biology
says will
maybe but he says we have one case that
we
know about earth but there have been
about
50 billion species some of them are
biologic biologically successful that
means they survive in proliferation
some of them are not the ones that
survive and proliferate are the dumb
ones
things like bacteria mutate very quickly
no problems or say beetles
remember old age famous comment that
god must have loved beatles he made so
many of them right
they're fine they find a niche they just
stick to it and
they get by but as you go up the scale
of what we call intelligence
survival gets lower and lower
large mammals for example are very rare
the only reason there's a lot of cows is
because we domesticate them
but if you look at wild in the wild
say apes or you know very few
they don't survive very well and if you
take
humans it's probably only the last
couple hundred thousand years
which means that several billion years
of life went by and never know humans
nothing with what we call
higher intelligence that's right to
extrapolate and ask
what might happen on other planets the
chances of
developing higher intelligence might not
be very high
yeah they just might not survive and
even if they're intelligent it doesn't
mean that they're technologically
advanced that they're able to interpret
and build build devices you know i
always say it takes
you can't build a solar panel you know
solar panels weren't built using
solar panels to provide power in other
words there's a hierarchy of energy
scales that were needed to construct
something as sophisticated or not as the
photovoltaic cell
tiny percentage of human life
but let's suppose that they there's
something like
human intelligence there would there be
ways to communicate
well i think the thing to do is not to
look at the printer
no they could have used one just like
humans we can use one or another sensory
motor system
we can use our hands we can use
touch you can even learn language from
touch
yes you can learn where you sound
because it's convenient
you do some other so i don't really
think that's the issue
the issue is the internal system
a system that constructs infinitely many
thoughts basically and if you look at
that
there's a good reason to think that
there might be
a mode of interaction namely arithmetic
if you take a look at the structure of
language
it's the internal system
there's pretty good evidence by now that
it's based on the most
elementary computational uh
device namely binary set formation
and if you take a look at binaries from
that you can construct the infinitely
many structures and so on
and if you take a look at that you can
from
binary set formation with a lexicon
of one element you basically get the
basis for arithmetic
uh there's kind of another direction
from which you could look at this
uh marv minsky
about 50 or 60 years ago
did some experiments in which he just
took the
simplest turing machines fewest states
and symbols
and ask what happens if you just let
them run wild
you know turns out almost all of them
crash
either they get into an infinite cycle
or they
where they terminate uh but some
survive and turned out they all had the
successor function
so and then he concludes well suppose
evolution is getting to the point where
it's developing
systems that have some of the capacities
of turing machines
it's going to hit on the simplest things
and the simplest things will give you
something like the basis for arithmetic
and maybe they'll give you language
that's
a point where there's possible
convergence
in order to pursue it you have to show
that so for example this point i made
about structure dependence
that actually follows directly from the
fact that the
basic computational system for language
is
binary set formation because that does
not yield linear order
so if that's the system that's in your
child's brain it's never going to use
linear order
it'll use it for communication but
that's because of the sensory motor
system
the sensory motor system requires linear
order
we can't talk in structures so you have
to linearize the thing
but that's a property of the printer has
basically nothing to do with language
sensory motor system was in place
hundreds of thousands millions of years
before language emerge
and it's basically nothing to do with it
just as your printer has nothing to do
with the
program and the laptop
so in in the absence of all systems
though
uh so the absence of a neuro
mechanistic touch uh sound
uh with these aliens it merely
communicating only with
arithmetic um you know symbolic symbolic
logic
that would be sufficient um
i assume that they have some mode of
externalizing what's in their heads
now if we can latch on to that mode of
communication that printer
that they're using then we could go back
to the internal system
it's a good reason to believe that they
would have the successor function in
addition
because the successor function addition
it's part of our language
so maybe that could be an entry point